Lucia: 是只把一楼的客厅装饰一下还是二楼的客厅
Jake: 要装饰就一楼吧
Jake: Let's decorate the first floor.
Jake: 然后还有各位的房间
Jake: And then everyone's rooms.
Jake: 我可能找个时间
Jake: I'll find some time,
Jake: 今天或者明天或者等你们收拾好
Jake: today or tomorrow, or after you guys tidy up,
Jake: 总之就是
Jake: basically,
Jake: 这几天我会把整个房子用iPhone扫一遍
Jake: in the next few days, I'll scan the whole house with my iPhone.
Jake: 嗯然后各位的卧室就收拾收拾
Jake: And then you guys can tidy up your bedrooms.
Jake: 对要扫进去
Jake: Need to scan everything.
Lucia: 那你要不扫之前通知一声
Lucia: How about you notify us before scanning?
Lucia: 对这样我就可以在扫之前
Lucia: So we can prepare before the scanning.
Lucia: 把那个箱子拉起来
Lucia: Pull that box up.
Tasha: 微微
Tasha: Weiwei
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 我这衣服没口袋这个东西
Lucia: My clothes don't have pockets for this thing.
Lucia: 要不然把它拔了
Lucia: Otherwise, just pull it out.
Lucia: 哈哈呃你看一下它有多少电
Lucia: Haha, uh, check how much battery it has.
Jake: 如果电很多的话没关系哦
Jake: If it has a lot of battery, it's fine.
Lucia: 我在手机上能看
Lucia: I can check on my phone.
Lucia: 到它有多少电好的
Lucia: To see how much battery it has, okay?
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Katrina:  嗯又找到他在这
Katrina: Hmm, found him here again.
Lucia: 93%页是不是应该可以把
Lucia: 93% should be fine, right?
Jake: 对你坐着的时候冲嘛
Jake: Yes, charge it while you sit.
Jake: 然后站着就还剩这些最后这
Jake: And then when you stand, you'll have this left.
Tasha: 最后一二三四五六六块没有
Tasha: The last one, two, three, four, five, six pieces, no?
Tasha: 找着家了
Tasha: Found the home.
Tasha: 看看像不像嗯像
Tasha: Check if it looks like it, hmm, it does.
Tasha: 但不一定他们俩在一起感觉
Tasha: But not necessarily, they are together, feels like.
Tasha: 这个在这边
Tasha: This is here.
Lucia: 他怎么突然变成network Arrow了
Lucia: How did it suddenly become network Arrow?
Jake: 好我看一下
Jake: Okay, let me see.
Jake: 可以给我看一下吗
Jake: Can you show me?
Lucia: 就是在我把电拔掉之后
Lucia: It suddenly switched to this screen after I unplugged it.
Lucia: 他突然变成这个界面了
Lucia: It just changed to this interface suddenly.
Lucia: 是哎对这样
Lucia: Yes, like this.
Shure:  你先把这几个字
Shure: You first deal with these characters.
Lucia: 这个什么意思
Lucia: What does this mean?
Jake: 重开一下
Jake: Restart it.
Jake: 我也没见过这个就我把它这样
Jake: I've never seen this before, let me do this.
Lucia: 就是这样关掉重开一下
Lucia: Just shut it down and restart.
Shure:  先先先来这个先先把一根给一边
Shure: First, first, first, give one side a stick.
Shure:  给那什么
Shure: Give it what it needs, okay.
Jake: 我这出不来
Jake: I can't get this out.
Shure:  你把那缩一下
Shure: Shrink that down.
Tasha: 这样这个猪就塞不下他
Tasha: This way the pig can't fit in.
Jake: 这个长度是对的吗
Jake: Is this length right?
Jake: 都一样的
Jake: All the same.
Shure:  都是一样
Shure: All the same.
Katrina:  的
Katrina: Yes.
Lucia: 啊出来了他应该还是正常的吧
Lucia: Ah, it's back, it should be normal, right?
Lucia: 可能是刚才有什么bug了嗯
Lucia: Yeah, maybe there was a bug earlier, hmm.
Jake: 或者装饰二楼
Jake: Or decorate the second floor.
Jake: 因为二楼的那个场地
Jake: Because the venue on the second floor...
Jake: 就做PPT比较方便
Jake: It's more convenient for making PPTs.
Jake: 就是就可以摆那个
Jake: We can just set up...
Jake: 摆摆椅子
Jake: Set up chairs.
Jake: 摆很多椅子
Jake: Set up a lot of chairs.
Lucia: 哦对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right.
Lucia: 因为二楼的桌子已经搬到那边去了
Lucia: Because the tables on the second floor have already been moved over there.
Jake: 对所以在二楼装饰
Jake: Yeah, so we'll decorate the second floor.
Tasha: 他们这家该放哪里呢
Tasha: Where should they put this?
Shure:  是让毛血刷的
Shure: This is for Mao Xue brush.
Alice: 哈哈但我觉得他俩又不像一家
Shure: Haha, but I think they don't look like a family.
Alice: 因为这个角不太好拼
Alice: Because this corner is hard to fit.
Alice: 就比较尖的角
Alice: It's a very sharp corner.
Alice: 有没有比较尖的角
Alice: Are there any sharp corners?
Lucia: 好复杂啊
Lucia: So complicated.
Tasha: 他的嘴是吗
Tasha: His mouth, right?
Jake: 哈哈剩了一圈了
Tasha: Haha, there's a whole circle left.
Jake: 这一圈很强
Jake: This circle is very strong.
Lucia: 但是感觉只有
Lucia: But it feels like only...
Lucia: 只有这几个是比较确定的
Lucia: Only these few are pretty certain.
Lucia: 我们找到了很多两个
Lucia: We found many pairs.
Lucia: 两个是一起的
Lucia: Two of them go together.
Lucia: 但是确定了放在哪里
Lucia: But we need to determine where to place them.
Tasha: 当然找不到他们的家
Tasha: Of course, we can't find their home.
Jake: 好多好朋友
Jake: So many good friends.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun...
Lucia: 哇哎这个真的好一致啊
Lucia: Wow, this really matches well.
Shure:  哎我去这个
Lucia: Whoa, how did you find this?
Lucia: 你是怎么找到的
Lucia: How did you find it?
Tasha: 他这有两个尖尖
Tasha: There are two sharp points here.
Jake: 我去这尖尖你能看到
Jake: Whoa, you can see those sharp points?
Jake: 眼神真好
Jake: Good eyesight.
Jake: 我这看不清
Jake: I can't see clearly.
Tasha: 哦这个弧度我之前看到过
Tasha: Oh, I've seen this curve before.
Jake: 有点6
Jake: Impressive.
Shure:  人生的最后7天
Shure: The last 7 days of life.
Shure:  来吧立起来
Shure: Come on, stand up.
Lucia: 会不会是那个鸟翅膀
Lucia: Could it be the bird's wings?
Shure:  哦还有一个是吗
Shure: Oh, there's one more, right?
Jake: 对还有一个
Shure: Yeah, one more.
Shure:  还有这个人
Shure: And this person too.
Tasha:  完美
Tasha: Perfect.
Lucia: 哎棒棒
Lucia: Yay, awesome, awesome, awesome.
Tasha: 那说明鸟不在边边
Tasha: So that means the bird isn't at the edge.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Hmm, right.
Alice: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this.
Tasha: 感觉这个弧度很
Tasha: Feels like the curve is...
Tasha: 很像
Tasha: Very similar.
Alice: 不像哎
Tasha: Not really.
Jake: 确实有点像
Jake: It does look a bit similar.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 这个也是对的
Lucia: This one is correct too.
Jake: 这是你记住的吗
Jake: Is this what you remember?
Tasha: 然后
Tasha: And then...
Tasha: 拿
Tasha: Take it.
Alice: 一个是吧
Alice: One, right?
Lucia: 我们刚才是不是给这个蛇
Lucia: Did we just find a buddy for this snake?
Lucia: 已经找到了一个小伙伴
Lucia: We already found a buddy for it.
Tasha: 对蛇跟那个熊猫哎
Tasha: Yes, the snake and the panda, right?
Alice: 怎么怎么怎么弄来着
Tasha: How did we do that again?
Lucia: 啊对对对
Lucia: Oh, right, right, right.
Alice: 有人长这样吗
Alice: Does anyone look like this?
Lucia: 好像不太有人长这样
Lucia: Seems like not many people look like this.
Shure:  无敌
Shure: Invincible.
Lucia: 嗯好像也不是呢
Lucia: Hmm, maybe not.
Jake: 把它弄一边长是吧
Jake: Make it grow longer on one side, right?
Shure:  对那把它竖过来倒过来
Jake: Yeah, then rotate it and flip it.
Tasha: 就还剩最后的
Tasha: So there's just the last one left.
Tasha: 这这两个也没找着家是吗
Tasha: These two haven't found a place yet, right?
Tasha: 还剩最后5个找着家的
Tasha: Only five left that have found their place.
Tasha: 要不尝试着把它们把这些放进去吧
Tasha: How about we try putting these in?
Tasha: 说不定形状就出来了
Tasha: Maybe the shape will come out.
Lucia: 这怎么放能让他不不位移
Lucia: How can we place them so they don't move?
Alice: 这俩像在一块吗
Alice: Do these two look like they go together?
Tasha: 像又不太像
Tasha: Kind of, but not really.
Lucia: 这个好像
Lucia: This one seems...
Lucia: 是不是很像在一起啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look like they're together?
Lucia: 这俩嗯
Lucia: These two, hmm.
Lucia: 然后这个如果还在这的话就是这样
Lucia: Then if this is still here, it should be like this.
Lucia: 接下来这里还缺一口
Lucia: Next, there's still a piece missing here.
Tasha: 我们已经越来越剧情真相了
Lucia: We're getting closer and closer to the truth of the story.
Lucia: 对哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, haha.
Tasha: 越来越有拼下去的动力了
Tasha: We're getting more and more motivated to keep going.
Tasha: 还有3个人无家可归
Tasha: There are still 3 people who are homeless.
Lucia: 这个哎不是他
Lucia: This, hey, it's not him.
Tasha: 这个感觉这个小家伙在哪都行
Tasha: This little guy seems like he's fine anywhere.
Tasha: 所以他好像不能放在里面
Tasha: So it seems he can't be put inside.
Lucia: 这如果有一个戳尖角的地方
Lucia: If there's a place with a sharp corner,
Lucia: 应该挺好找的才对啊
Lucia: It should be pretty easy to find.
Alice:超过盘了哦
Alice: It's over the limit.
Lucia: 啊，对不起
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Lucia: 这个猫好像不在这里
Lucia: This cat doesn't seem to be here.
Lucia: 这造型会是什么呢
Lucia: What could this shape be?
Lucia: 这个嘛
Lucia: This, well...
Lucia: 那好像又不是真想要完全放进去
Lucia: It seems like it's not meant to be put in completely.
Tasha: 可是就是会有点边角的
Tasha: But there will be some edges, I think.
Tasha: 我感觉
Tasha: I feel like.
Lucia: 甜品
Lucia: Dessert.
Tasha: 这个是在这的吧
Tasha: This should be here, right?
Lucia: 哎是是是
Lucia: Oh yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: Hehehe.
Lucia: 那这个应该就不在
Lucia: Then this shouldn't be here.
Lucia: 我感觉这个不对了
Lucia: I feel like this is wrong.
Tasha: 对这个不对
Tasha: Yes, this is wrong.
Lucia: 塞进去了
Lucia: It's stuck in.
Alice: 不对那这个肯定在这
Lucia: No, then this must be here.
Lucia: 这个真的
Lucia: This really...
Lucia: 怎么看都有点像一个猫
Lucia: It looks a bit like a cat.
Lucia: 或者之类的东西
Lucia: Or something like that.
Tasha: 可能不清
Tasha: Maybe it's unclear.
Alice:这个头吗
Alice: This head?
Alice: 也不是
Alice: It's not either.
Tasha: 嗯这是松
Tasha: Hmm, this is loose.
Jake: 可以这是荒野去排练
Jake: Okay, this is the wilderness rehearsal.
Lucia: 无限尝试
Lucia: Endless attempts.
小薇 : 刚刚这个
Tasha: Just now, this...
Tasha: 刚刚这个是归谁吗
Tasha: Just now, who did this belong to?
Alice: 这个不归谁
Tasha: This doesn't belong to anyone.
Tasha: 啊行
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Alice: 哎啊对啊
Alice: Ah, yeah, right.
Tasha: 他们仨是归着的呀
Alice: The three of them are grouped together.
Tasha: 他们仨是归着的
Tasha: Oh yeah, yeah, the three of them are grouped together.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: 然后这还有一组
Lucia: And here is another group, here's another group.
Alice: 这个这个有归家吗
Alice: Does this one have a home?
Lucia: 刚才咱是不是他和熊猫也是能拼起来的
Lucia: Just now, wasn't it him and the panda that could be put together?
Lucia: 不是他是蛇和熊猫
Lucia: No, it's the snake and the panda.
Lucia: 那这个豹子
Lucia: Then what about this leopard?
Shure: 他俩应该不是不穿一起
Shure: The two of them shouldn't be together.
Tasha: 这豹子这个平平的面很好找呀
Tasha: This leopard with a flat side is easy to find.
Shure:  看图
Shure: Look at the picture.
Lucia: 有没有可能豹子
Lucia: Is it possible the leopard is somewhere else?
Lucia: 在别的什么地方
Lucia: In some other place?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Tasha: 这里这样子的
Alice: It's like this here.
Lucia: 哎可以可以对对对
Lucia: Ah, this fits, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 只剩最后两个人
Tasha: Only two people left.
Tasha: 没有家可以跪了
Tasha: Nowhere to go home.
Tasha: 没有家可以归了
Tasha: 然后我们就可以放到左边
Tasha: Then we can place them on the left.
Lucia: 他们有没有可能也是在边上的
Lucia: Could it be they are also on the edge?
Lucia: 这一圈看着还挺像一个弧度的
Lucia: This circle looks quite like an arc.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 那这还直
Tasha: Then this is still straight.
Tasha: 这正好还差一个边
Tasha: This just happens to be one edge missing.
Alice: 对你说的那个平平的是不是这个
Alice: Is the flat one you mentioned this one?
Alice: 这可能不在那边
Alice: This might not be over there.
Lucia: 就是这个可能他是一个边
Lucia: Maybe this is an edge.
Lucia: 跑了
Lucia: It's gone.
Lucia: 这样子的然后这个在这
Lucia: Like this, and then this is here.
Lucia: 他们他们有点
Lucia: They, they kind of...
Lucia: 有点像是一个边
Lucia: Kind of look like an edge.
Lucia: 对他们有点像是一个边
Lucia: Yeah, they kind of look like an edge.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 虽然不是100%确定
Lucia: Although it's not 100% sure.
Tasha: 嗯有可能是这样子的
Lucia: Hmm, it might be like this.
Tasha: 哎他们俩正好就这样子了
Tasha: Ah, the two of them just fit like this.
Tasha: 嗯OK了
Tasha: Hmm, OK.
Tasha: 本来他们俩还分开了
Tasha: They were separated at first.
Jake: 比划比划要不
Jake: Want to give it a try?
Lucia: 哦原来这个牛
Lucia: Oh, so this is awesome.
Lucia: 底下这里是k塌子啊
Lucia: The bottom here is a k-frame, huh?
Lucia: 我就说这个地方应该很好
Lucia: I knew this place would be great.
Tasha: 刚刚找了半天
Tasha: Been searching for a while.
Tasha: 这人正好就找进去了
Tasha: And then this person just found it.
Lucia: 歪打正着
Lucia: A lucky break.
Tasha: 现在感觉把边整理整理
Tasha: Now it feels like we should tidy up the edges.
Tasha: 然后再把这几个组进去就行了
Tasha: Then we can just put these few pieces together.
Lucia: 这现在这些个编的顺序我们拼的
Lucia: The order we arranged these in might not be correct.
Lucia: 不一定是对的
Lucia: It might not be right.
Tasha: 这个先拿修一下
Tasha: Let's fix this one first.
Tasha: 是不是这样子
Tasha: Is it like this?
Alice: 你觉得这个像不像边
Alice: Do you think this looks like an edge?
Lucia: 也有一点
Lucia: Kind of.
Lucia: 放进去试试
Lucia: Try fitting it in.
Tasha: 我刚把哪个取出来来着
Tasha: Which one did I just take out?
Alice: 就这样是不像一个边
Alice: It doesn’t look like an edge like this.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Alice: 也像一个边
Alice: It does look like an edge.
Lucia: 那这里需要放一个什么吗
Lucia: Do we need to put something here?
Alice: 哎这个吗
Alice: Is it this one?
Lucia: 有可能把他推过来
Lucia: Maybe we can push it over.
Alice: 哎拼上了哦
Alice: Oh, it fits now.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Lucia: 我刚找到了
Lucia: I just found it.
Shure:  哎智慧
Shure: Hey, smart move.
Tasha: 我刚刚这样
Tasha: I just did it like this.
Lucia: 接近真相了啊这
Tasha: 这3个都是怎么拼来着
Tasha: How did we piece these three together?
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Tasha: 就这样啊
Tasha: Just like this.
Tasha: 就这个地方
Tasha: Just this place.
Lucia: 挨着这里挨着这里
Lucia: Close to here, close to here.
Lucia: 呃，推一下试试看
Lucia: Uh, try pushing it.
Alice:他俩拼到了
Alice: They fit together.
Lucia: 他俩拼到了
Lucia: They both matched it.
Tasha: 哎呀，刚刚那个呢
Tasha: Oh no, what about the last one?
Lucia: 好好好真相只有一个
Lucia: Okay, okay, there's only one truth.
Tasha: 啊，我，我
Lucia: Ah, I, I...
Lucia: 再往好像再往这里推一点点
Lucia: Push it a little bit more this way.
Lucia: 就是往这个方向推一点点
Lucia: Just push it a bit in this direction.
Lucia: 怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Just...
Lucia: 这好像还挺像的
Lucia: This looks quite similar.
Tasha: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 有可能是动
Lucia: It might be moving.
Lucia: 那接下来的这一边这个弧线呢
Lucia: And this curve here?
Lucia: 难道是这个吗
Lucia: Could it be this one?
Lucia: 哦这样子的Lucia: 然后他们是一个弧线哎小心
Lucia: Oh, like this. Be careful, they are in a curve.
Tasha: 弧形
Tasha: Curved.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 有没有可能呢
Lucia: Is it possible?
Lucia: 角度好像稍微有点卡住了
Lucia: The angle seems a bit stuck.
Lucia: 可以有点像
Lucia: It kind of looks like it.
Lucia: 但怎么感觉好像不完全对似的
Lucia: But it doesn't seem quite right.
Tasha: 因为这还有这么大块呢
Tasha: Because there is still such a big piece left.
Tasha: 对我感觉会这么一大块
Tasha: Yeah, I feel it should be a big piece.
Tasha: 蘑菇味
Tasha: Mushroom flavor.
Lucia: 他们应该都这这
Lucia: They should all be like this.
Lucia: 这一块这么不规则
Lucia: This piece is so irregular.
Lucia: 他应该是在中间的吧
Lucia: It should be in the middle, right?
Lucia: 嗯他会在哪
Lucia: Hmm, where would it be?
Tasha: 我把它先取出来
Tasha: I'll take it out first.
Lucia: 哎有点像那个地方啊
Lucia: Hey, it looks like that spot.
Lucia: 好像也不是
Lucia: Maybe not.
Tasha: 先把他放进去吧
Tasha: Let's put it in first.
Lucia: 哎好像可以可以可以
Lucia: Hey, it seems like it fits.
Lucia: 对好像可以
Lucia: Yes, it seems to fit.
Lucia: 哎但这样的话
Lucia: But if we do this,
Lucia: 这里好像又拼不上了
Lucia: This part doesn't match.
Lucia: 但这两个肯定是挨着
Lucia: But these two pieces must be together.
Lucia: 可是没事
Lucia: But it's okay.
Alice: 这个边不一定在这
Alice: This edge might not be here.
Alice: 把这个边先拿出来
Alice: Let's take this edge out first.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: It could work.
Lucia: 那就把那个牛和那个啥放一起
Lucia: Then put the cow and that other thing together.
Lucia:然后这个是在
Lucia: And then this goes here.
Lucia: 但这个好像是在他的上面
Lucia: But this seems to be on top of it.
Lucia: 这样子的
Lucia: Like this.
Lucia: 然后这里再有一个
Lucia: And then there's another one here.
Tasha: 这个边也不一定对对
Tasha: This side might not be right.
Lucia: 对这个边的位置
Lucia: Yeah, this side's position.
Lucia: 等一下把这个边合开
Lucia: Wait, separate this side.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Tasha: 可是这个边是一对的呀
Tasha: But this side is correct.
Lucia: 这应该是对的
Lucia: This should be right.
Lucia: 这一圈应该是对的
Lucia: This whole area should be correct.
Tasha: 只有这个边和这个边位
Tasha: Only this side and this side are in place.
Lucia: 好奇怪啊
Lucia: So strange.
Alice: 要不
Alice: How about...
Alice: 先把这个不确定的边先给他拿出来
Alice: We take out the uncertain pieces first.
Lucia: 有些有脚吗
Lucia: Do some have legs?
Lucia: 这个做不出来这个地方
Lucia: This part can't be done.
Tasha: 你知道咋拼来着
Tasha: Do you know how to put it together?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 是的但这个其实也还蛮像的
Lucia: Yes, but this actually looks quite similar.
Alice: 家咋拼来着
Alice: How do we put this together?
Alice: 谁和我看过这个
Alice: Who watched this with me?
Tasha: 这个和谁是一家来着
Tasha: Who goes with this one?
Lucia: 这个这个这个和现在
Lucia: This one, this one, and now...
Lucia: 和他们吧
Lucia: With them, right?
Lucia: 哎等等
Lucia: Wait a minute.
Tasha: 它谁是一家来着
Tasha: Who goes with this one?
Lucia: 对对他和这个和这个鹰我记得是
Lucia: Yes, yes, it goes with this eagle, I remember.
Lucia: 在你翅膀的某一个地方
Lucia: It's somewhere on your wing.
Lucia: 可能是这这这
Lucia: Maybe here, here, here.
Lucia: 对的对的
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 然后这样子
Lucia: And then like this.
Alice: 哎这个咋拼来着
Alice: How do we put this together?
Alice: 怎么一会拼着拼着拼
Alice: Why do I get confused while putting it together?
Alice:拼迷糊了
Alice: I'm getting so muddled.
Lucia: 这个半圆怎么还
Lucia: Why is this semicircle still...
Lucia: 缺一部分
Lucia: Missing a part?
Tasha: 哦哦找到了
Tasha: Oh, oh, found it.
Lucia: 找到了找到了
Lucia: Found it, found it.
Lucia: 在这里
Lucia: Over here.
Tasha: 哇我们仨是天才
Tasha: Wow, the three of us are geniuses.
Lucia: 这这这几个刚刚怎么回事来着
Lucia: What just happened with those pieces?
Jake: 因为我们活动场地有可能在这
Jake: Because our activity area might be here.
Jake: 因为我们活动场地有可能在这  Lucia: 这样的是吧对对对
Lucia:  怎么还少一块啊
Lucia: How come there's still a piece missing?
Lucia: 咋回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Tasha: 少一块
Tasha: A piece is missing.
Lucia: 会不会是他
Lucia:耶耶
Lucia: Yay, yay.
Lucia: 胜利近在眼前
Lucia: Victory is within reach.
Lucia: 这个地方是不是在这里啊
Lucia: Is this place supposed to be here?
Lucia: 那就不不太一样
Lucia: Then it's not quite the same.
Lucia: 不完全一样
Lucia: Not exactly the same.
Lucia: 他就那边大一些啊
Lucia: It's just bigger over there.
Lucia: 又散了
Lucia: It's scattered again.
Tasha: 你颤音了
Tasha: You were trembling.
Tasha: 崩溃了
Tasha: I'm breaking down.
Lucia: 收集一些拼图数据可还行
Lucia: Collecting some puzzle data, how about that?
Tasha: 让AI知道
Tasha: Let AI know.
Lucia: 快了快了
Lucia: Almost there, almost there.
Alice: 这俩咋拼一起
Alice: How do these two pieces fit together?
Lucia: 我们现在可以整体根据这个形状
Lucia: We can now look at the overall shape.
Lucia: 来看一看
Lucia: Let's take a look.
Alice: 他们到这这啊
Alice: They go here, right?
Alice: 哇天才
Alice: Wow, genius.
Lucia: 可以可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 对的对的
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 来哎
Lucia: Come on, hey.
Alice:放进去放进去放进去
Alice: Put it in, put it in, put it in.
Lucia: 那我觉得那个鹰翅膀就是在这里
Lucia: 我觉得鹰翅膀就是在这里
Lucia: I think the eagle's wing goes here.
Lucia: 稍等，我们比划比划
Lucia: Wait a minute, let's measure it.
Tasha: 如果鹰翅膀放在这里的话哎
Tasha: If the eagle's wing is here, then...
Tasha: 屁股就撅在这是吧
Tasha: The tail would be here, right?
Lucia: 对这屁股应该是在这个地方吧
Lucia: Yes, the tail should be in this place, right?
Lucia: 对对对，鹰翅膀在这的
Lucia: Yes, yes, the eagle's wing is here.
Lucia: 然后鹰翅放在这啊
Lucia: And then the wing goes here.
Tasha: 蛇啊这蛇在这呢
Tasha: Snake, the snake is here.
Lucia: 哇太不容易了
Lucia: Wow, that was really tough.
Lucia: 对了对了，然后这个这个
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, and then this, this.
Lucia: 这个松鼠
Lucia: This squirrel.
Lucia: 好像在鹰翅膀这里
Lucia: Seems to be on the eagle's wing here.
Alice: 哈哈哈不行
Alice: Hahaha, no way.
Alice: 这个要最后放
Alice: This should go last.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 因为他哪都可以
Lucia: Because it can go anywhere.
Lucia: 怕他嘛来吧
Lucia: Scared of it? Come on.
Alice: 我们见证奇迹的时刻
Alice: We're witnessing a moment of miracle.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈太难了
Alice: Hahahahaha, this is so hard.
Lucia: 太不容易了
Lucia: This is really tough.
Alice: 来我们录一下这个数据瞅一眼
Alice: 好你来
Alice: Okay, you do it.
Lucia: 快快快这可是人类早期
Lucia: Quick, quick, quick, this is from early human times.
Lucia: 好不容易拼出拼图的珍贵数据
Lucia: It's precious data from a puzzle hardly put together.
Tasha: 哈哈哈快来快来
Tasha: Hahaha, come on, come on.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:来了来了来了来了来了
Shure: I'm coming, coming, coming, coming, coming.
Lucia: 拼好了哈哈哈
Lucia: It's done, hahaha.
Jake: 好强啊我
Jake: I'm so strong.
Alice:累死了
Alice: So tired.
Lucia: 太不容易了哇靠
Lucia: This was really tough, oh my.
Jake: 太强了
Jake: So strong.
Jake: 用了多久
Jake: How long did it take?
Lucia: 不知道多久
Lucia: No idea how long.
Jake: 应该半个多小时
Jake: Probably more than half an hour.
Katrina:  所以土地公公在哪
Katrina: So where's the Earth God?
Lucia: 哪个土地公公这啊
Lucia: Which Earth God? Here?
Lucia: 他就在边上哈哈
Lucia: He's right next to it, haha.
Jake: 这个到时候秀给客人
Jake: We'll show this to the guests.
Jake: 这个还有点脸面
Jake: This gives us some face.
Jake: 哼这我们拼好了
Jake: Hmph, we finished this.
Jake: 就我们拼好然后你们再来拼
Jake: And then you guys do it.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 他上面是不是还有
Lucia: Is there more on top?
Lucia: 一个一个笋就这样子卡住了
Lucia: A bamboo shoot just stuck like this.
Lucia: 应该就这脸啊
Lucia: Should be just this face.
Alice: 应该，没了就这点啊
Lucia: 啊，那
Lucia: Ah, then...
Jake:这个也可以研究一会
Jake: We can study this for a bit too.
Jake: 那这个是不是可以那
Jake: So, can we do this then?
Lucia: 那这个是不是可以
Lucia: 那那是他俩互相掐一点
Lucia: Then they can pinch each other a bit.
Lucia: 哎呦哎呦小心小心别撒了
Lucia: Oh, be careful, careful, don't spill it!
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 放平吧要不好了啊
Shure: Lay it flat, or it'll be bad.
Lucia: 对然后就这样子夹住
Lucia: Right, then just clamp it like this.
Katrina:  稳定的三角形结构
Katrina: A stable triangular structure.
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Good.
Lucia: 为了防止它散还可以就先装进来
Lucia: To prevent it from falling apart, we can put it here first.
Lucia: 这样挡一下感觉
Lucia: Block it like this, I think.
Lucia: 对这样就不容易块就不容易掉出来
Lucia: Right, this way it won't fall out easily.
Lucia: 哎把这一边朝着另外那一边
Lucia: Hey, turn this side towards the other side.
Alice: 好呀哈哈
Alice: Okay, haha.
Lucia: 小心哈哈
Lucia: Careful, haha.
Alice: 土地公掉了不该冒这个险
Alice: The Earth God fell, shouldn't have taken this risk.
Alice: 好的这次我不冒险
Alice: Okay, I won't take the risk this time.
Lucia: 哎这个拼好蛮好看的
Lucia: Hey, this looks pretty good when put together.
Lucia: 就不知为何
Lucia: Just don't know why...
Lucia: 有种日本服饰会的那种画风的感觉
Lucia: It has a feel of Japanese traditional art.
Lucia: 啊哈哈
Lucia: Ahaha.
Alice: 这样耶头挤着屁股的这种
Alice: Like this, head squeezed against the butt.
Alice: 和谐相处
Alice: Living in harmony.
Jake: 哈哈哈看一看有多和谐
Jake: Hahaha, let's see how harmonious it is.
Alice: 和谐吗
Alice: Harmonious?
Lucia: 特别和谐
Lucia: Very harmonious.
Lucia: 就在我们的这个地球上
Lucia: Just on our Earth...
Lucia: 和谐共处哦
Lucia: Living in harmony.
Jake: 就熊猫后面他很开心的感觉
Jake: The panda at the back looks really happy.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈这个表情
Jake: Hahaha, that expression.
Jake: 嚯你们拼的是真不容易
Jake: Wow, what you guys put together wasn't easy.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是吗
Lucia: Haha, really?
Jake: 看得出来看得出来
Jake: I can tell, I can tell.
Lucia: 尝试了好长时间
Lucia: Tried for a long time.
Lucia: 因为他每个边都要
Lucia: Because every side needs...
Jake: 这一些你们怎么拼起来的呀
Jake: How did you guys put these together?
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This part...
Alice: 就是找那种你看像这种比较紧密的
Alice: Just look for the ones that are closely fit together like this.
Alice: 哦哦就先拼起来
Alice: Oh, oh, just piece it together first.
Alice: 然后大块大块大块的看
Alice: Then look at the big chunks, big chunks, big chunks.
Alice: 最后大块怎么拼起来
Alice: Finally, piece the big chunks together.
Jake: 对我看上面的可能还好一点
Jake: Right, I think the ones on top might be a bit better.
Tasha: 对就
Tasha: Yeah, just...
Lucia: 是的这种就找到找到边缘
Lucia: Yes, find the edges like this.
Alice: 对对对就是差不多最后拼起来
Alice: Yes, yes, yes, about the final piece coming together.
Jake: 这个边缘确实还挺圆的
Jake: This edge is actually quite round.
Lucia: 嗯除了这一块但是后面就是这
Lucia: Hmm, except for this part, but after that...
Lucia: 这部分拼好之后
Lucia: After we piece this part together...
Lucia: 我们就发现他这个弧度很像是这个圆
Lucia: We found out that this curve looks a lot like this circle.
Lucia: 所以就还是放在边上
Lucia: So we'll still put it on the edge.
Alice: 哦你看一下
Alice: Oh, look at this.
Alice: 一开始这个就不在这个弧的考虑范围
Alice: At first, this wasn't considered in the curve.
Lucia: 对嗯对障眼法
Lucia: Yes, hmm, right, it's a trick.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Alice: 累死的路啊
Alice: Exhausting path.
Lucia: 好有成就感啊
Lucia: Feels so accomplished.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我不敢想象
Tasha: I can't imagine.
Tasha: 如果后面客人来玩这
Tasha: If guests come to play later...
Tasha: 玩一个小时会不会想走
Tasha: Will they want to leave after an hour of playing?
Lucia: 哈哈哈客人可能拼一拼就
Lucia: Hahaha, guests might piece a bit and then...
Lucia: 哎呀不拼了我们要下一个节目哈哈
Lucia: Ah, forget it, let's move on to the next activity, haha.
Jake: 我们琢磨琢磨
Jake: Let's think about it.
Jake: 这个要要不看看你的开箱
Jake: How about we check out your unboxing?
Tasha: 我的开箱啊
Tasha: My unboxing?
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Jake:你有好的东西要不给我们秀一秀
Jake: You have good stuff, why not show them to us?
Lucia: 哎我的刚才
Lucia: Oh, mine just now...
Lucia: 哎我的刚才不用吧
Jake: Oh, mine just now, no need.
Lucia: 哦在这
Lucia: Oh, it's here.
Tasha: 这是做蛋糕的模具
Jake: No need to show the cake molds.
Tasha: 4寸和6寸的
Tasha: 4-inch and 6-inch.
Tasha: 裱花嘴
Tasha: Decorating tips.
Katrina:  打蛋器
Katrina: Egg beater
Tasha: 打蛋器搅拌棒
Tasha: Egg beater, mixing rod
Jake: 太专业了
Jake: So professional
Tasha: 裱花嘴
Tasha: Piping tip
Tasha: 薄脆
Tasha: Crisp
Tasha: 刮板
Tasha: Scraper
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake: 刮板刮板哦哦哦
Jake: Scraper, scraper, oh oh oh
Tasha: 啊也可以平的也可以切面团
Tasha: Ah, it can be flat or cut dough
Jake: 明白明白
Jake: Got it, got it
Tasha: 这个想的是做
Tasha: This is for making
Alice: 杯子的那种对
Alice: The cup kind, right
Lucia: 纸杯甜点那种吗
Lucia: Like cupcake kind?
Tasha: 对饮料应该也行
Tasha: Yes, drinks should work too
Jake: 30306090120是吧一盒30 卖的话是吗
Jake: 30306090120, right? A box of 30. Selling price, right?
Jake: 对定价多少钱
Jake: Yes, how much is the price?
Tasha: 定价啊定价一般1515
Tasha: Pricing, pricing, usually 15, 15
Lucia: 那是紫薯粉吗
Lucia: Is that purple sweet potato powder?
Tasha: 吉利丁粉
Tasha: Gelatin powder
Tasha: 啊凝固用的
Tasha: Ah, for solidifying
Tasha: 你要最量
Tasha: You need the most amount
Shure:  咱们纸抽在哪
Shure: Where are our tissues?
Jake: 呃这边怎么了
Jake: Uh, over here. What's up?
Shure:  摆摆桌子上养的让娃找纸找不到
Shure: Put them on the table. Can't find tissues for the kid.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Alice: 哎我们的拼图呢
Alice: Hey, where's our puzzle?
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: Here it is
Lucia: 哎呀幸好外面有一层
Lucia: Oh, luckily there's an outer layer
Alice: 来欣赏
Alice: Come appreciate it
Jake: 摇起来
Jake: Shake it
Alice: 电子秤
Alice: Electronic scale
Tasha: 还有的袋子呢
Tasha: And the bags?
Jake: 这边有很多
Jake: There are many here
Jake: 是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Tasha: 呃这些对吧
Tasha: Uh, these, right?
Tasha: 用
Tasha: Use
Tasha: 纸杯
Tasha: Paper cups
Tasha: 呃量温度的
Tasha: Uh, for measuring temperature
Jake: 烤箱在哪
Jake: Where's the oven?
Tasha: 打蛋器
Tasha: The egg beater.
Jake: 那我们放哪呢
Jake: So, where should we put it?
Jake: 我放哪比较合适
Jake: Where's the best place to put it?
Tasha: 削皮刀哪
Jake: Where's the peeler?
Tasha: 放这呗这我觉得应该放烤箱上面
Alice: Put it here, I think it should go on the oven.
Alice: 呃微波炉上面会比较合适
Alice: Uh, it might be better on the microwave.
Shure:  咱这边只有微波炉
Shure: We only have a microwave here.
Jake: 你买烤箱了
Jake: Did you buy an oven?
Tasha: 温度计烤箱温度计
Tasha: Thermometer, oven thermometer.
Jake: 白烤蛋糕黑巧吗
Jake: Are we baking the cake with dark chocolate?
Tasha: 对黑巧做那种熔浆蛋糕
Tasha: Yes, make that molten chocolate cake.
Katrina:  好专业啊
Katrina: So professional.
Katrina:  好专业啊这
Alice:这提拉米苏那个叉
Alice: That Tiramisu fork.
Alice: 对对对提拉米苏的叉
Alice: Yes, yes, the Tiramisu fork.
Tasha: 还有提拉米苏的盒子哪呢
Tasha: Where's the Tiramisu box?
Tasha: 嗯这伯爵红茶包
Tasha: Hmm, this Earl Grey tea bag.
Jake:这些东
Jake: These things...
Jake: 西昨天应该都扫一遍
Jake: We should have cleaned everything yesterday.
Jake: 扫一天
Jake: Clean for a day.
Tasha: 可可粉
Tasha: 这个是那个咖啡酒
Tasha: This is the coffee liqueur.
Tasha: 咖啡酒
Tasha: Coffee liqueur.
Katrina:  你会调酒吗
Katrina: Do you know how to make cocktails?
Shure:  我啊嗯
Shure: Me? Hmm...
Shure:  看起来会一点
Shure: I look like I know a bit.
Jake: 哈哈哈看一下
Jake: Hahaha, let's see.
Lucia: 最最简单的
Lucia: The simplest one.
Lucia: 买一瓶威士忌
Lucia: Buy a bottle of whiskey.
Lucia: 买买几瓶可乐
Lucia: Buy a few bottles of cola.
Lucia: 然后兑一块就完事了
Lucia: Then just mix them together and you're done.
Katrina:  咱有多少个杯子呀
Katrina: How many cups do we have?
Katrina:  有20个杯
Katrina: We have 20 cups.
Shure:  有上面6个下面6个 12
Shure: There are 6 on the top, 6 on the bottom, 12.
Lucia:  哎，小心
Katrina: Oh, be careful.
Jake: 我靠这什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 架上去吧
Jake: Put it up there.
Shure:  咱们经费这么充足吗
Shure: Do we have such a big budget?
Shure:  我感觉我是不是应该花花呀
Shure: I feel like I should spend some money too.
Katrina:  哈哈咱都是他的助手
Katrina: Haha, we are all his assistants.
Jake: 对这边主要花了
Jake: Yeah, spent quite a bit here.
Jake: 花了很有用的很多费用
Jake: Spent a lot on useful stuff.
Katrina: 买点柠檬片
Katrina: Let's buy some lemon slices.
Jake:非常有用
Jake: Very useful.
Katrina:  我来记一下
Katrina: I'll write it down.
Alice: 啊对我也要买柠檬
Alice: Oh right, I need to buy lemons too.
Jake: 嗯对下午要买东西就记一下菜单吧
Jake: Yeah, let's make a shopping list for the afternoon.
Jake: 或者单写写在这个白板上面
Jake: Or just write it down on this whiteboard.
Jake: 这个白板现在你们都可以写吧
Jake: You can all write on this whiteboard, right?
Jake: 比较好写
Jake: It's pretty easy to write on.
Shure:  这白板拍一下拍
Shure: Just take a picture of the whiteboard.
Jake: 拍完了然后擦
Jake: Take a picture, then erase.
Jake: 再拍一下擦掉吧
Jake: Take another picture, then erase it.
Jake: 都可以调监控的
Jake: You can always adjust the surveillance.
Katrina:  提拉米菲
Katrina: Tiramisu.
Lucia: 哦那个手指饼干
Lucia: Oh, the ladyfingers.
Shure:  哈哈哈哇真的好赛博呀
Shure: Haha, wow, this is so cyber!
Shure:  看一眼我拍完你的
Shure: Look at this, I took a picture of yours.
Tasha: 但这家特别贵
Tasha: But this place is really expensive.
Tasha: 还好经费充足
Tasha: Good thing we have enough funds.
Alice: 大手套
Alice: Big gloves.
Jake: 很多酒
Jake: Lots of liquor.
Tasha: 切蛋糕胚的
Tasha: For cutting cake layers.
Lucia: 这个怎么用啊
Lucia: How do you use this?
Tasha: 就是你把这个固定器冷冻还是有冷藏
Tasha: You just freeze or refrigerate the stabilizer.
Lucia: 一些知识盲区
Alice: 比如说你不是切了一个蛋糕了吗
Alice: Like, you cut a cake, right?
Alice: 然后就把这两个固定就固定在第几层
Alice: Then you fix these two at the layer you want.
Alice: 然后呢用这个刀这样横着过去
Alice: Then you use the knife to slice horizontally.
Alice: 对然后他就会切出来很平整的面
Alice: Yeah, and it will give you a flat surface.
Alice: 换手套吗
Alice: Changing gloves?
Tasha: 无菌手套
Tasha: Sterile gloves.
Tasha: 黄豆粉
Tasha: Soybean powder.
Katrina:  嗯嗯养乐多
Katrina: Yeah, Yakult.
Tasha: 嗯糯米粉
Tasha: Sticky rice flour.
Tasha: 两勺没了
Tasha: That's it, wow.
Lucia: 好丰盛的材料
Lucia: Such a bountiful selection of ingredients.
Lucia: 这边挪一点
Lucia: Move this a bit.
Lucia: 这个是我的
Lucia: This is mine.
Lucia: 我的眼镜盒
Lucia: My glasses case.
Lucia: 哎这个水是
Lucia: Hey, this water is...
Tasha: 没开的吧
Tasha: Unopened, right?
Lucia: 没开的那我可以开一瓶吗
Lucia: It's unopened. Can I open a bottle?
Lucia: 啊这瓶开过了
Lucia: Ah, this bottle is opened.
Lucia: 有点渴
Lucia: I'm a bit thirsty.
Lucia: 这瓶好像没开过
Lucia: This bottle seems unopened.
Jake: 要不贴个名字吧
Jake: How about we put a name tag on it?
Jake: 有那个小贴纸
Jake: There are those little stickers.
Jake: 有道理还在吗
Jake: Makes sense, are they still there?
Jake: 嗯找不着了
Jake: Hmm, can't find them.
Alice: 这好好看
Alice: This looks nice.
Alice: 你可以在这折个角
Alice: You can fold a corner here.
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Lucia: 但是如果大家都折了一个角的话
Lucia: But if everyone folds a corner...
Alice: 不一样的角
Alice: Different corners.
Jake: OK那那能记住哈
Jake: OK, then we can remember it.
Alice: 过来有个人是一个撕掉
Alice: Someone could tear off a bit.
Jake: 写一下吧
Jake: Just write it down.
Lucia: 我把外面就撕下来
Lucia: I'll just tear off the outer part.
Lucia: 给他叠个花
Lucia: And fold it into a flower.
Lucia: 笔在这里
Lucia: The pen is here.
Lucia: 我先简单在这个白的地方随手写一下
Lucia: I'll quickly write something on this white part.
Katrina:  你们毕设这么早吗
Katrina: You guys are working on your final projects so early?
Shure:  我们还有个模拟答辩
Shure: We still have a mock defense.
Shure:  很奇怪啊
Shure: It's quite strange.
Lucia: 你们还有模拟答辩
Lucia: You guys still have a mock defense?
Katrina:  论文还没写
Katrina: Haven't even written the thesis yet.
Shure:  哦你是软件工程的是吧
Shure: Oh, you're in software engineering, right?
Katrina:  嗯好
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Shure:  帮我改改代码吧
Shure: Help me fix my code then.
Shure:  到时候哈哈哈
Shure: Later, haha.
Katrina:  帮你改代码
Katrina: Help you fix your code?
Katrina:  我自己代码还没跑完呢
Katrina: I haven't even finished running my own code.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure:  太爽了
Shure: Feels so good.
Shure:  出去搞杯咖啡喝
Shure: Let's go get a coffee.
Shure:  在外面坐一坐晒晒太阳
Shure: Sit outside and enjoy the sun.
Shure:  无敌了
Shure: Invincible.
Jake: 点外卖了吗
Jake: Did you order takeout?
Katrina:  还没吃午饭吗
Katrina: Haven't had lunch yet?
Lucia: 对，现在几点了
Lucia: Yeah, what time is it now?
Jake: 一点不饿是吧
Jake: Not hungry at all, huh?
Lucia: 一点半了
Jake: 对我们再录40分钟就结束了这一轮
Jake: Yeah, we'll finish this round in another 40 minutes.
Jake: 然后40分钟能干嘛呢
Jake: So what can we do in 40 minutes?
Jake: 点个外卖
Jake: Order takeout.
Jake: 就是有40分钟外卖差不多能到吧
Jake: The takeout should arrive in about 40 minutes, right?
Jake: 然后大概准备一下下午买点啥
Jake: Then we can think about what to buy in the afternoon.
Jake: 在这写一写
Jake: Write it down here.
Jake: 拉倒了
Jake: Never mind.
Tasha: 做东西
Tasha: Make stuff.
Tasha: 就是在一楼做是吗
Tasha: Make it on the first floor, right?
Jake: 在一楼做
Jake: On the first floor.
Jake: 哦我就是问问
Jake: Oh, I was just asking.
Jake: 对在一楼做
Jake: Yes, on the first floor.
Jake: 然后在这摆这个
Jake: And then set this up here.
Jake: 这个就当就是工作台
Jake: This will be the workbench.
Lucia: 工作台工作台
Lucia: Workbench, workbench.
Jake: 和甜点的那个台子放在也是这边是吧
Jake: And the dessert table will be over here too, right?
Shure:  不是就是他
Shure: No, it's just...
Jake: 这就是一个厨房
Jake: This is a kitchen.
Jake: 全是礼物
Shure: All gifts.
Shure:  我也带稍微带一点
Shure: I'll also bring a little bit.
Tasha: 把所有的模具都放到这个袋子里
Tasha: Put all the molds in this bag.
Shure:  开飞机就要很大的钱
Shure: Flying a plane costs a lot of money.
Lucia: 这个哦哦这是
Lucia: This, oh oh, this is...
Lucia: 这是某位同学的眼镜
Lucia: These are someone's glasses.
Lucia: 我还以为是我们戴的这个太像了
Lucia: I thought they were ours, they look so similar.
Shure:  混淆你们用的
Shure: Confusing with yours.
Jake: 我这个擦掉了
Jake: I wiped this off.
Jake: 你们想写就写
Jake: You can write if you want.
Lucia: 眼镜中混入了一个叛徒
Lucia: There's a traitor among the glasses.
Shure:  AI中混住了一个傻子哈哈哈
Shure: There's an idiot among the AI, hahaha.
Lucia: 哎这个白板没有背面吗
Lucia: Hey, doesn't this whiteboard have a backside?
Lucia: 只有一面
Lucia: Only one side?
Jake:有背面
Jake: There's a backside.
Jake: 背面是个黑板
Jake: The backside is a blackboard.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah OK
Jake: 对可以用粉笔写啊
Jake: Yeah, you can use chalk to write.
Jake: 他还给红笔
Jake: He also gave a red pen.
Lucia: 原来是这样的设计
Lucia: Oh, so that's the design.
Alice: 对这个是这备用的一套是吗
Alice: Yeah, this is the backup set, right?
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: It's that one.
Lucia: 这个刀是吗
Lucia: This knife, right?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 啊小心手
Lucia: Ah, careful with your hand.
Lucia: 这个挺利的
Lucia: This is pretty sharp.
Lucia: 我们家好像拿这个打过
Lucia: I think we used this at home before.
Lucia: 果汁之类的东西
Lucia: For things like juice.
Jake: 要不整点咖啡
Jake: How about making some coffee?
Jake: 咖啡整很好了是吧
Jake: The coffee is ready, right?
Jake: 啊咖啡整好了
Jake: Ah, coffee is ready.
Shure:  咖啡好像没有那么多
Shure: Seems like there's not much coffee.
Shure:  哦哦而且只只能手冲
Shure: Oh, and we can only make hand-poured coffee.
Jake: 那每人喝一口吧
Jake: Then let's share a cup.
Jake: 哈哈哈一小杯就是温笑的啊
Jake: Hahaha, a small cup is just enough to warm up.
Shure:  OK温笑咖啡
Shure: OK, a warm-up coffee.
Shure:  咖啡也按烧腾喝是吧
Shure: We drink coffee like it's burning hot, right?
Shure:  对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  直接烧腾浓缩
Shure: Directly a burning hot espresso.
Shure:  哈哈对
Shure: Haha, yes.
Lucia: 我我刚开始点是不会点
Lucia: When I started, I didn't know how to order.
Lucia: 真的点过一烧腾
Lucia: I really ordered a burning hot one.
Lucia: 浓缩上来的时候我都惊呆了
Lucia: When the espresso came, I was shocked.
Lucia: 啊这是点咖啡
Lucia: Ah, this is how you order coffee?
Lucia: 我刚开始不会点
Lucia: I didn't know how to order at first.
Lucia: 然后就是点过那种纯的espresso就一shot
Lucia: And then I ordered a pure espresso, just one shot.
Lucia: 然后上来我真的惊呆了
Lucia: And when it came, I was really shocked.
Lucia: 这怎么喝
Lucia: How do you drink this?
Shure:  我们现在开始中午饭
Shure: We're starting lunch now.
Jake: 午饭点外卖
Jake: Let's order lunch.
Jake: 外卖点什么呢
Jake: What should we order for delivery?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's see.
Shure: 吃的点什么
Shure: What should we eat?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 美团外卖
Jake: Meituan delivery.
Shure: 美团外卖送啥都快
Shure: Meituan delivery is super fast.
Lucia: 呃那个是干嘛的呀
Lucia: Uh, what's that for?
Lucia: 就是就是用来放它的吗
Lucia: Is it for putting it on?
Lucia: 嗯那个垫子
Lucia: Hmm, that mat.
Alice:对要不然它会跑
Alice: Yeah, otherwise it would run away. Oh, okay, got it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 他是用来干嘛的
Tasha: What's it for?
Alice: 做他的烂吃
Alice: To cook his food.
Shure: 打空气的
Shure: For air.
Jake: 报个菜名
Jake: Name a dish.
Jake: 吃我请您吃
Jake: I'll treat you.
Shure:  我请大家吃
Shure: I'll treat everyone.
Shure:  何帆不认识饭
Shure: He Fan doesn't know rice.
Shure:  牛肉饭加锅炉
Shure: Beef rice with boiler.
Shure:  小锅牛肉吉野家
Shure: Small pot beef from Yoshinoya.
Shure:  肯德基宅基送聚德
Shure: KFC delivery to Ju De.
Shure:  上北京烤鸭老街春饼
Shure: Peking duck from Lao Jie Chun Bing.
Shure:  南城香饭香串香馄饨香
Shure: Nan Cheng Xiang, fragrant rice, fragrant skewers, fragrant wontons.
Shure:  小栋酿猪脚饭
Shure: Xiao Dong braised pork feet rice.
Shure:  酱骨饭汉堡王本味龙江猪脚饭
Shure: Stew rice, Burger King, Benwei Longjiang pork feet rice.
Shure:  人民公社大食堂神话烤鱼
Shure: People's Commune Canteen, Myth Grill Fish.
Shure:  便益坊烤鸭河间驴肉火烧
Shure: Bianyifang roast duck, Hejian donkey meat sandwich.
Shure:  河谷烧
Shure: He Gu roast.
Shure:  日料寿司田老师红烧肉张记京味卤煮
Shure: Japanese sushi, Teacher Tian's braised pork, Zhang Ji Beijing-style stewed food.
Shure:  他们肯定一个都没记住
Shure: They probably didn't remember any of that.
Shure:  哈哈哈自己都没记住
Shure: Haha, I didn't even remember it myself.
Lucia: 我就听到一个KFC
Lucia: I only heard KFC.
Jake: 好那就KFC吧怎么样
Jake: Okay, then KFC, how about it?
Lucia: 不不不我只是只记得这个
Lucia: No, no, no, I just remembered that one.
Lucia: 因为太快了
Lucia: Because it was too fast.
Jake: 汉堡王啊
Jake: How about Burger King?
Jake: 汉堡可以就就肯德基
Jake: If you want a burger, let's go with KFC.
Jake: 就KFC给外国人一些小震撼
Jake: Just KFC to give the foreigners a little shock.
Lucia: 我我没有忌口
Lucia: I don't have any dietary restrictions.
Lucia: 所以大家吃什么都行
Lucia: So, whatever everyone wants is fine.
Lucia: 我想吃那奥尔良我都可以疯了
Lucia: I want to eat that, I could go crazy.
Shure:  KFC KFC全家桶
Shure: KFC, KFC family bucket.
Jake: 呃有些新品
Jake: Uh, some new items.
Jake: 热辣不羁全是肉
Jake: Spicy and rebellious, all meat.
Jake: 尊享无敌披萨
Jake: Premium Invincible Pizza
Jake: 下面全是肉的披萨
Jake: A pizza with all meat underneath
Jake: 炸鸡炸鸡为对
Jake: Fried chicken, fried chicken, right
Jake: 这个披萨
Jake: This pizza
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 衣服没裹上我就先把这个再拔下来了
Lucia: Since the clothes aren't covered, I'll remove this first
Lucia: 这样我就可以自由活动
Lucia: That way I can move freely
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 反正这里面垫应该还够
Lucia: Anyway, the padding inside should be enough
Tasha: 这个放烤箱里
Tasha: This goes in the oven
Lucia: 这个也是放这里面吗
Lucia: Does this go in here too?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Lucia: 需要把要洗的东西单独挑出来一下吗
Lucia: Do we need to separate the things that need washing?
Jake: 好啊啊你们
Jake: Sure, you guys
Lucia: 好的对那这个
Lucia: Okay, then this
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 路亚一般不会第一个选是吧
Jake: Lure is usually not the first choice, right?
Lucia: 哦对我一般都follow
Lucia: Oh right, I usually follow
Lucia: 就是大家选过的选项
Lucia: I pick what others have picked
Lucia: 就是点菜的时候好
Lucia: Like when ordering food, oh those glasses
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no
Lucia: 这个是不是也要拆一下
Lucia: Should we also take this apart?
Lucia: 就是撒糖霜的那个是吧
Lucia: Like the one for sprinkling powdered sugar, right?
Shure:  老板你你吃鸡堡
Shure: Boss, do you want a chicken burger
Shure:  吃牛堡
Shure: Or a beef burger?
Jake: 我能吃那个披萨吗
Jake: Can I have that pizza?
Lucia: 这有垃圾桶
Lucia: There's a trash can here
Shure:  有人吃鸡堡吗
Shure: Anyone wants a chicken burger?
Tasha: 好我不想吃堡
Tasha: Nah, I don't want a burger
Jake: 好那你可以吃
Jake: Okay, you can have it
Jake: 那你想吃什么
Jake: So what do you want to eat?
Jake: 你不想吃肯德基是吧
Jake: You don't want KFC, right?
Tasha: 不是不是我不想吃汉堡
Tasha: No, no, I just don't want a burger
Jake: 哦哦哦鸡肉卷
Tasha: Oh, oh, a chicken wrap
Tasha: 要帮你吗
Jake: Need help?
Shure:  一个奥尔良
Shure: One 2-ounce
Shure:  然后一个
Shure: And then one
Jake: 好好你帮我推进去
Shure: Okay, help me push it in
Jake: 我把这个弄起来
Jake: I'll take care of this
Lucia: 这个袋子要拆掉吗
Lucia: Should we open this bag?
Tasha: 都要拆的
Tasha: We need to open all of them.
Jake: 走走一波
Shure: Let's get moving.
Tasha: 呃我先把线扯好的
Tasha: Uh, let me fix the line first.
Tasha: 扯掉把线洗
Tasha: Pull it off and wash it.
Lucia: 这种时候
Lucia: At this moment...
Lucia: 我就把它系一下好了
Lucia: I'll just tie it up.
Lucia: 要不然老拖地
Lucia: Otherwise, it keeps dragging on the floor.
Tasha: 这其实还可以烤烤鸡来着
Tasha: Actually, you can roast some chicken with this.
Jake: 妙妙
Jake: Wonderful.
Lucia: 裱花嘴一会再拆吧
Lucia: Let's leave the piping nozzle for later.
Lucia: 别散的不知道到哪去了
Lucia: Otherwise, we might lose track of it.
Tasha: 这这些都是材
Tasha: These are all ingredients.
Tasha: 食材就行啊
Tasha: Just the ingredients are fine.
Tasha: 把粉的放一起
Tasha: Put the powders together.
Tasha: 食材放一起
Tasha: Keep the ingredients together.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK OK.
Lucia: 这些也都要拆掉了是吧
Lucia: These all need to be opened too, right?
Katrina:  这都是粉
Katrina: These are all powders.
Tasha: 粉放到哪里呢
Tasha: Where should we put the powders?
Tasha: 粉就放这吧
Tasha: Just put the powders here.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这些颗都给他
Lucia: Give all these pieces to him.
Lucia: 塞一块上
Lucia: Stuff them together.
Jake: 点完了
Jake: Finished ordering.
Jake: 点了几个
Jake: How many did you order?
Jake: 点了个双人餐
Shure: Ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  对那是我
Shure: Yes, that was me.
Shure:  我点了一个双人餐
Shure: I ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 你一个人点了个双人餐
Jake: You ordered a meal for two by yourself?
Shure:  不是我我和那个
Shure: No, it's for me and...
Shure:  雨轩对
Shure: Yuxuan, yes.
Jake: 好是什么呢
Jake: Okay, what's this?
Lucia: 哦，这个是那个备用刀片
Jake: 电池呢是电池啊啊
Jake: Batteries, it's batteries, right?
Tasha: 巧克力搁这会不会化呀
Tasha: Will the chocolate melt if we leave it here?
Lucia: 要不放冰箱要不放冰箱
Lucia: Let's put it in the fridge, put it in the fridge.
Tasha: 还有套餐吗
Tasha: Are there more combos? Haha.
Jake: 搜一搜
Jake: Search for it.
Jake: 没有哎有是是这个吗
Jake: No, is this the one?
Tasha: 那这不就一个吗
Tasha: Isn't there just one?
Jake: 那就没有了
Jake: Then there's none left.
Tasha: 那好吧那
Tasha: Okay then.
Jake:还是这个吧
Jake: Let's stick with this one.
Jake: 不用套餐好的单点一些喝的是吗
Jake: No need for a combo, just order some drinks, right?
Tasha: 喝的不用了吧
Tasha: No need for drinks.
Jake:好没了
Jake: Alright, that's it.
Jake: 嗯还有吗
Jake: Is there anything else?
Tasha: 没了别的呢
Jake: Nothing else?
Jake: 这些小东西
Jake: These little things.
Tasha: 那我跟着他们吃吧
Tasha: I'll just follow what they're eating.
Lucia: 这也是粉
Lucia: This is also powder.
Lucia: 巧克力是不是有两包
Lucia: Is there two packs of chocolate?
Lucia: 还有一包也是
Lucia: And there's another pack too.
Jake: 点了三个
Jake: Ordered three.
Lucia: 那我们要不然就放在啊粉类放在这边
Lucia: Should we place all the powder items here?
Lucia: 这个地方不是很容易晒到
Lucia: This spot doesn't get much sun.
Alice: 巧克力给我吧
Tasha: Give me the chocolate.
Alice:可以放冰箱
Lucia: It can be put in the fridge.
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: Here's one for you.
Lucia: 这个是放在外面还是要放到冰箱去
Lucia: Should this be kept outside or put in the fridge?
Jake: 你要套餐吗还是单点
Jake: Do you want a combo or just order separately?
Jake: 你要喝的吗
Jake: Do you want a drink?
Lucia:我要这个 咖啡酒
Lucia: I'll have this, coffee liquor.
Tasha: 咖啡酒放冰箱
Tasha: Coffee liquor goes in the fridge.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 要不这也放冰箱吧
Tasha: Maybe put this in the fridge too.
Tasha: 没地方放
Tasha: No space.
Lucia: 行反正冰箱里东西少空间多
Lucia: Fine, there aren't many things in the fridge, lots of space.
Tasha: 这个硅油纸啊小心谁把它放进去的
Tasha: Be careful with this parchment paper, who put it in here?
Lucia: 啊，小心
Lucia: Ah, be careful.
Lucia: 这个稍微往边上挪一点好
Lucia: Move it slightly to the side, okay?
Jake: 来吧到你了
Jake: Come on, it's your turn.
Lucia: 让我看看大家都点了什么
Lucia: Let me see what everyone ordered.
Lucia: 一般来说
Lucia: Generally speaking,
Lucia: 榴榴莲味的东西都有一点奇奇怪怪的
Lucia: Durian-flavored things are always a bit weird.
Shure:  我呢还有一大瓶伏特加
Shure: I still have a big bottle of vodka.
Lucia: 哎让我参考一下
Lucia: Hey, let me take a look.
Alice: 还有一个托盘
Alice: There's another tray.
Tasha: 哎这其实还有个托盘
Tasha: Hey, there's actually another tray.
Shure:  你对啥都基本上喝不出它本来
Shure: You basically can't taste the original flavor of anything.
Shure:  这是什么呀
Shure: What is this?
Jake: 这就是接人嘛
Jake: This is just for meeting people.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 我们有几个接人
Jake: We have a few people to meet.
Shure:  我是pJake:路亚是接人批p
Shure: I'm p Jake: Luya is meeting people p
Shure:  天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Lucia: 万不得已复联计划那种
Lucia: Only in emergencies, like the Avengers plan.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha, XX.
Jake: 唯一的
Jake: The only.
Jake: 站着吧完了
Jake: Stand there, it's done.
Jake: 哈哈哈这个地方
Jake: Hahaha, this place.
Jake: 这地方就是你的
Jake: This place is all yours.
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: I'll give you one.
Jake: 划一个区哈哈
Jake: Let's mark out a zone, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈这一区把j人围起来观察
Lucia: Haha, let's use this area to observe the people.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 看到这个是不是很不爽
Jake: Doesn't this just annoy you?
Jake: 这些东西都要把它干掉
Jake: We need to get rid of all these things.
Alice: 这个给他搁哪好
Alice: Where should we put this?
Tasha: 这个是备用的刀片
Tasha: This is a spare blade.
Tasha: 然后不用搁哪
Tasha: No need to put it anywhere.
Tasha: 这个也是搁这吧
Tasha: This can go here too.
Tasha: 我感觉这个没这个好使
Tasha: I feel like this one isn't as good as this.
Alice: 那就给他搁这吧
Alice: Then just put it here.
Tasha: 嗯行
Jake: Yeah, okay.
Jake: 这个能晒吗
Jake: Can this be dried?
Jake: 这些东西
Jake: These things.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure:  我们在我们在观摩街园哈哈哈
Shure: We're, we're watching the street garden, hahaha.
Lucia: 哎肯德基现在居然还有牛肉汉堡了
Lucia: Wow, KFC has beef burgers now.
Shure:  对你这这些东西我都拿伏特加对过
Shure: Yeah, I've tried all these things with vodka.
Shure:  都基本是一个味
Shure: They all basically taste the same.
Jake: 我先把这个填起来
Jake: Let me fill this out first.
Shure:  哎呀哎哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh my, oh my, oh my.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 真是多才多艺这是
Jake: You're really multi-talented.
Lucia: 这是怎么发出的声音
Lucia: How did that sound come out?
Jake: 12个12个现在
Jake: Twelve, twelve now.
Lucia: 我好了
Lucia: I'm ready.
Jake:好的
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Almost there.
Shure:  杯子就再说
Shure: About the cups...
Shure:  先不用买了
Shure: No need to buy them for now.
Jake: 我们点了
Jake: Let's place an order.
Shure:  觉得差不多
Shure: I think that's about right.
Jake: 我们总共三个
Jake: We've got three in total.
Jake: 可乐也行吧
Jake: Cola works too, right?
Shure:  好像是我除了可乐
Shure: I think except for the cola...
Shure:  我一会要coffee
Shure: I'll need coffee later.
Shure:  coffee没有coffee会死的
Shure: Without coffee, I'd die.
Jake: 我们要哎
Jake: We need...
Jake: 肯德基是不是不用餐具点俩吧
Jake: KFC, we don't need utensils, right? Let's order two.
Lucia: 呃咱们早上有剩下的餐具
Lucia: Uh, we have leftover utensils from the morning.
Jake: 哦那就点3个因
Jake: Oh, then let's order three because...
Jake: 为剩下的三个是吧
Jake: We have three left, right?
Lucia: 啊
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 哎不记得剩下几个啊
Lucia: Oh, I don't remember how many are left.
Alice: 餐具哦哎等一下
Alice: Utensils, oh wait.
Alice: 动作太大
Alice: Too much movement.
Jake: 好滴点了
Jake: Alright, ordered.
Jake: 大家等饭吃吧
Jake: Let's wait for the food, everyone.
Lucia: 我们我们要调几种酒啊
Lucia: How many types of alcohol do we need to mix?
Shure:  能调啥
Shure: What can we mix?
Lucia: 基酒的话
Lucia: For base spirits...
Lucia: 威士忌和龙舌兰也可以考虑一下
Lucia: We can consider whiskey and tequila.
Shure:  没事我明天
Shure: No worries, tomorrow...
Lucia: 我投楼上来日出一票哈哈
Lucia: I'll vote for a sunrise cocktail. Haha.
Shure:  我明天回宿舍看看有什么拿点
Shure: I'll check my dorm tomorrow and bring some.
Lucia: 如果买了兰姆的话不买龙舌兰也行
Lucia: If we buy rum, we don't need tequila.
Lucia: 我觉得风味还是有一点相似之处的
Lucia: I think the flavors are somewhat similar.
Jake: 大概去个两次吧应该
Jake: Probably need to go twice, I guess.
Jake: 多的话就只能靠剧组带了
Jake: If we need more, we'll have to rely on the crew to bring them.
Tasha: 剧组今天怎么不来
Tasha: Why didn't the crew come today?
Jake: 剧组上课去了啊哈哈
Jake: The crew went to class, haha.
Jake: 剧组很忙
Jake: The crew is very busy.
Jake: 兼组剧组兼职剧组
Jake: Juggling between crew duties.
Shure:  精神支柱好吗
Shure: Are you the mental support?
Lucia: 呃如果如果我买了那个柳橙汁的话
Lucia: Uh, if I buy that orange juice...
Lucia: 也可以用气泡酒
Lucia: We could use sparkling wine too.
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Like...
Lucia: mimosa会也是果汁
Lucia: Mimosas are also made with juice.
Lucia: 果汁味浓一些然后酒精度低过水
Lucia: The juice flavor would be stronger and the alcohol content lower.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And...
Lucia: 因为我不太确定大家喜欢喝什么样的
Lucia: Because I'm not sure what everyone likes to drink.
Lucia: 我感觉果味的
Lucia: I feel like fruity ones...
Katrina:  我感觉果偏果味的大家应该都能接受
Katrina: I feel like everyone can accept fruity ones.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina: 就是喝着玩吗
Katrina: Just for fun, right?
Lucia: 我们我们好像还有果粒橙是吧
Lucia: We still have some orange juice with pulp, right?
Lucia: 那好像不买橙汁也行
Lucia: Then we might not need to buy orange juice.
Lucia: 椰汁要不先可以加入一下清单
Lucia: We could add coconut juice to the list.
Lucia: 然后一会大家考虑一下
Lucia: And then we'll consider it later.
Lucia: 呃我看一下椰林飘香怎么调来着
Lucia: Uh, I'll check how to make a Pina Colada.
Shure:  行d万能的
Shure: Alright, it's versatile.
Shure:  啊西柚味那个是容器
Shure: Ah, the grapefruit flavor one is the container.
Tasha: 休息一下
Tasha: Take a break.
Tasha: 你已经整理过很多东西了
Tasha: You've already sorted a lot of stuff.
Jake: 没关系是的
Jake: It's okay, really.
Jake: 然后他们采购的东西补一补
Jake: And then we'll replenish the supplies they bought.
Lucia: 对但是其实也不一定非要放这么多
Lucia: Yes, but we don't necessarily need to add so much.
Lucia: 就是朗姆酒加椰汁兑
Lucia: Just mix rum with coconut juice.
Lucia: 然后我个人觉得可能就菠萝汁
Lucia: Then I personally think maybe pineapple juice...
Lucia: 换成别的果汁也行
Lucia: Could be replaced with another juice.
Lucia: 因为咱也不需要调的那么正经嘛对吧
Lucia: We don't need to make it too formal, right?
Lucia: 所以可以考虑一下
Lucia: So we can consider it.
Lucia: 对我
Lucia: Yeah, I...
Lucia: 其实我觉得只要有可乐
Lucia: Actually, I think as long as we have cola...
Lucia: 跟任何东西都可以兑一起
Lucia: It can be mixed with anything.
Jake: 我们还有20分钟就结束了这一段
Jake: We have 20 minutes to finish this segment.
Jake: 然后20分钟之内
Jake: And within 20 minutes...
Jake: 呃就就把这些事情都给截掉
Jake: Uh, let's wrap up these things.
Jake: 然后是一个完整的片段
Jake: Then we'll have a complete segment.
Shure:  好吧好那我们就这个片段
Shure: Alright, then let's go with this segment.
Shure:  就是5个批人观察一个勾人的计划
Shure: It's about five people observing a baiting plan.
Shure:  对就是我们现在就收尾
Shure: Yeah, we're wrapping it up now.
Jake: 就不要开心的事情了就把这个给收掉
Jake: Let's skip the happy stuff and just wrap this up.
Lucia: 那我们就大家围在一起观察一下吧
Lucia: So, let's all gather around and observe.
Tasha: 帮我写一下
Tasha: Help me write it down.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 你们要不做啊
Jake: Are you guys going to cook the eggs?
Shure:  鸡蛋每天早上咱们可以煮着吃无菌蛋
Shure: We can boil the eggs every morning.
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs.
Lucia: 每天早上煮
Lucia: Boil them every morning.
Tasha: 嗯买吧白糖还有盐也需要一小包
Tasha: Hmm, let's buy some sugar and a small pack of salt too.
Tasha: 你可以写在一起
Tasha: You can write it all together.
Shure:  晚上整一个寿喜锅吃
Shure: Let's have a sukiyaki for dinner.
Jake: 寿喜锅嗯
Jake: Sukiyaki, hmm with eggs.
Alice: 用无菌蛋吧
Alice: Use pasteurized eggs.
Tasha: 对用无菌蛋也更好一些了
Tasha: Yeah, using pasteurized eggs is better.
Shure:  那还可以生吃
Shure: Then we can eat them raw too.
Shure:  每天早上
Shure: Every morning.
Tasha: 呃鸡蛋汤
Tasha: Uh, egg soup.
Tasha: 嗯也可以买点装饰薄荷什么
Tasha: Hmm, we could also buy some mint for decoration.
Tasha: 调酒是不是也可以用
Tasha: Maybe we can use it for cocktails too.
Tasha: 薄荷百里香什么都可以
Tasha: Mint, thyme, anything would work.
Tasha: 保鲜膜保鲜膜
Tasha: Plastic wrap, plastic wrap.
Tasha: 这有吗
Tasha: Do we have any? No, right?
Jake: 呃我没看到应该没有吧
Jake: Uh, I didn't see any, probably not.
Jake: 路亚看过没有对吧
Jake: Lucia, did you check? No, right?
Lucia: 没有应该是没有
Lucia: No, probably not.
Lucia: 应该没有
Lucia: Probably not.
Lucia: 好的他们这餐具只有
Lucia: Okay, they only have utensils.
Lucia: 比如说那个锅碗瓢盆这些
Lucia: Like pots, pans, and bowls.
Alice: 这个纸箱还要吗
Alice: Do we still need this cardboard box?
Lucia: 这纸箱要不要留一下
Lucia: Should we keep this cardboard box?
Lucia: 假如我们
Lucia: In case we...
Jake:留着留着
Jake: Keep it, keep it.
Lucia: 对对假如我们要做一些什么纸箱
Lucia: Yeah, in case we need to make something with it.
Lucia: 狗之类的可以摆在门口
Lucia: Like a dog to place at the door.
Lucia: 然后就当迎宾
Lucia: And use it as a greeter.
Alice: 那能把纸箱都留着
Alice: Then let's keep all the cardboard boxes.
Jake: 对纸箱留着吧
Jake: Yeah, keep the cardboard boxes.
Jake: 放在外面那种
Jake: Put them outside.
Lucia: 那种特别软特别薄的就不需要了
Lucia: The really soft and thin ones, we don't need those.
Lucia: 或者说就是破破损面积很大那种
Lucia: Or the ones that are very damaged.
Lucia: 没事我来吧
Lucia: It's okay, I'll handle it.
Lucia: 我可以查查看
Lucia: I can check it out.
Lucia: 那个很酷的杜宾应该怎么做
Lucia: How should we deal with that cool Doberman?
Shure:  我今天回家啊我回宿舍补给
Shure: I'm heading home today, going back to the dorm for supplies.
Shure:  想想啊有音箱话筒然后咖啡
Shure: Let's see, there's the speaker, microphone, then coffee and strawberries.
Lucia: 那就大概过上三四天左右再去
Lucia: So maybe we should go again in about three or four days.
Lucia: 买一次对
Lucia: Buy everything again, right?
Tasha: 那就没有了
Tasha: That's all we have.
Lucia: 外援
Lucia: Reinforcements.
Shure:  不咖啡豆我没了
Shure: No, I'm out of coffee beans.
Shure:  我需要买
Shure: I need to buy some.
Shure:  趁机补给我对
Shure: I'll restock while I'm at it.
Shure:  咖啡的一些东西
Shure: Some coffee supplies.
Shure:  嗯以及泡咖啡
Shure: And brewing coffee.
Lucia: 这个手套要不
Lucia: What about these gloves?
Lucia: 放这好了
Lucia: Just put them here.
Jake: 对我们这边只有一个j
Jake: Yeah, we only have one J here.
Jake: 然后没有s
Jake: And no S.
Lucia: 竟然没有s
Lucia: No S at all?
Jake: 没有s
Jake: No S.
Jake: 是我们总共30多个报名的人里边
Jake: Out of the 30 people who signed up, only three wanted
Jake: 就三个要
Jake: these two S slots.
Jake: 要这两个s
Jake: Just two S.
Tasha: S是啥
Jake: What's S again?
Alice: s觉得这种事没有意义
Alice: S thinks this kind of thing is meaningless.
Lucia: 有可能s比较
Lucia: Maybe S is more
Jake: s是是啥好像是
Jake: S is like, what was it again?
Jake: 什么感性和直觉和感觉
Jake: Something about intuition and feeling.
Lucia: 直觉和感觉好像是
Lucia: Intuition and feeling, I think.
Jake: 对实感
Jake: Yeah, real sense.
Jake: 就这个实在是没法打官司
Jake: This really can't be taken to court.
Lucia: 哈哈哈原来如此
Lucia: Hahaha, I see.
Lucia: 那所以是p人更多还是j人更多
Lucia: So, are there more P people or J people?
Lucia: 按照按照就是最终的结果来说的话
Lucia: Based on the final results, I mean.
Lucia: 应该报名的时候也是p人多
Lucia: During registration, there were more P people too.
Jake: 对对对压倒性的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it's overwhelming.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Lucia: 哎这个可这个可以扔了吗
Lucia: Hey, can I throw this away?
Lucia: 这里面还有一个
Lucia: There's one more in here.
Lucia: 这个也
Lucia: This one too.
Lucia: 应该也是裱花嘴的时候要用的啊
Lucia: I think it's for piping, right?
Tasha: 对这是转换器
Tasha: Yeah, that's an adapter.
Lucia: 那这个放在跟那些放一起吧
Lucia: Let's put this with the others.
Lucia: 然后这个可以扔了对吧
Lucia: And this can be thrown away, right?
Lucia: 对那就扔掉了
Lucia: Okay, then let's toss it.
Jake: 就是第一波那个
Jake: It was the first wave.
Jake: 呃复活节的那一次
Jake: Uh, during Easter.
Jake: 呃那报名的里边只有三个
Jake: Uh, there were only three people who signed up.
Jake: 只有三种
Jake: Just three.
Jake: 只有只有三种
Jake: Only three.
Jake: 这个NBTI
Jake: This NBTI.
Lucia: 只有三种
Lucia: Only three types.
Jake: 对总共十几个人总共我们把那个把这个喝了吧
Jake: Yeah, a total of over ten people.
Shure:  美汁源喝了吧
Shure: Let's drink it.
Lucia: 幸好最后我没有复活
Lucia: Luckily, I didn't revive.
Lucia: 结局吧因为突然
Lucia: The ending was sudden.
Lucia: 就是就是突然之间
Lucia: It was just so sudden.
Lucia: 我就是那一周事情还蛮多的
Lucia: I had a lot going on that week.
Lucia: 然后我一直忙到就是来这之前的一周
Lucia: And I was busy until the week before coming here.
Shure:  哎这有一篇那个
Shure: Hey, there's an article.
Lucia: 所以还是是机缘巧合的
Lucia: It was all a coincidence.
Lucia: 很荣幸认识大家
Lucia: Nice to meet everyone.
Alice: 对要做那啥的啊
Alice: Yeah, we need to do that thing.
Tasha: 这还可以煮火锅哎
Tasha: We can cook hot pot here.
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 哎对火锅也比较方便
Lucia: Yeah, hot pot is convenient.
Lucia: 买一些简单的食材
Lucia: Just buy some simple ingredients.
Lucia: 火锅底料直接煮就好了
Lucia: Use hot pot base, and it's done.
Tasha: 丸子羊肉片
Tasha: Meatballs and lamb slices.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Sounds good.
Lucia: 我们自己做饭的环节
Lucia: For our cooking session.
Lucia: 不如就做火锅
Lucia: Let's just make hot pot.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay